Democrats say they won in a why
president Trump fired another of his
administration's internal watchdogs
State Department Inspector General Steve
linic lost his job Friday Paula Reed is
at the White House Paula the president
has removed five inspectors general
since March what do we know about linic
good morning Anthony the CBS News has
learned he was investigating Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo and it was Pompeo
himself that recommended that linic be
removed now congressional Democrats are
demanding all records related to Linux
firing Robert Menendez wrote we
unalterably opposed the politically
motivated firing of inspectors general
and the president's gutting of these
critical positions CBS News has learned
the watchdog was looking into whether
secretary Pompeo misused a political
appointee at the State Department to
perform personal tasks for himself and
his wife a White House official tells
CBS News Secretary Pompeo recommended
the move and president Trump agreed on
Face the Nation Sunday Speaker Nancy
Pelosi suggested when expiring could be
an illegal dismissal but the fact is if
it looks like it's in retaliation for
something that the attorney the IG the
Inspector General is doing that could be
unlawful Republican senator Susan
Collins tweeted the president has not
provided the kind of justification for
the removal of IG linic required by this
law linic is the fifth government
watchdog president Trump has removed
during the corona virus pandemic
yesterday white house trade advisor
Peter Navarro defended the move saying
that the president needs people who were
loyal to his agenda congressional
Democrats have given the White House
until Friday to turn over all records
related to this decision Tony all right
Paula thank you very much